welcome back everybody lifelong member
of the nevada wolf pack
and former nfl player stefan jefferson
can now add
author to his resume with the children
new children's book out now
stefan welcome to the show
hi how's it going thanks for having me
i'm super honored super blessed
thank you so are we to have you on the
show thank you for joining us first
and foremost of course let's introduce
the book to our audience the adventures
of luxton the world changer i love that
title
what inspired you to write this what's
it about you know it's uh it's about
leadership and uh two years ago i was at
a sermon
and i heard this uh the sermon was on
oversight there's two meanings to
oversight there's a negative meaning and
there's a positive meaning
and the positive team is having
management over something
and i took that and i was like man i
wish i would have had better
oversight over my whole football career
and
and doing the whole nfl thing but i you
know i was like you know what i want to
make sure that
my son does everything better than i
could
and i just decided to write a book and
the book is about leadership and i'm
just
super blessed of just the journey it's
taken to actually get the book published
that's awesome what are your hopes for
the book what message do you want
children that are reading it to receive
and remember you know as they grow up
um the message that i would want the the
kids to know is that they can be
anything they want to do
and if you were if you want to be a
dentist you want to be a doctor if you
want to be a plumber
if you want to be a pizza man you can do
anything you want to do as long as you
serve that gift
so uh that's the message that i'm trying
to bring to everybody and encourage
parents to encourage their kids to
whatever they want to do they can do it
wow i feel like that's a good message
for adults too kids adults anybody
exactly yeah so where can people
actually buy the book
uh everyone can buy it at barnes noble's
and amazon
and it's soon to get on a walmart online
walmart books a million
and yeah it's uh it's you can get it
pretty much
at amazon everyone everyone's going to
amazon nowadays so i would say go to him
keep it virtual keep it virtual thank
you so much stefan wish you the best of
luck and
blessings to you and your family thank
you i appreciate it
all right all right we will